now also tonight yet more bewildering
blunders from yes the often giggling
vice president kamala harris who wants
to let us know she really likes the
internet i mean really likes it take a
look
context well the internet is an
essential part of life in the 21st
century can't get around it
can't get around without it
biden kamala and nancy pelosi
god help us all right now despite not
yet completing any of our other jobs you
know securing the southern border the
white house is now giving the vice
president more responsibilities now
heading up something called an online
policy task force whatever the hell that
means now you might be wondering what
exactly that task force will do
well at this point it seems to be
anybody's guess even the white house
press secretary doesn't appear to know
take a look
on the online policy task force at the
vice president's leading that's getting
kicked off today um on a background call
last night we were told that it's going
to be different from the disinformation
governance board
in that it's going to focus on illegal
conduct online but the memo creating it
was a little bit broader and mentioned
and i'm quoting from the document uh
quote online harassment abuse and
disinformation campaigns targeting women
and lgbtqi plus individuals who are
public and political figures
could you clear up the disinformation
charge so i would need to uh talk to her
team i was not on the background call so
that specific uh
language that you're you're providing to
me i would just have to check in with
her
in other words i don't know a thing
about it either hills reaction former
presidential candidate democratic
congresswoman uh tulsi gabbard is with
us all right
i would like america to go back to the
trump policies and secure our border i
would like to go back to the policies
that america is energy independent and
stop sucking up to iran venezuela opec
uh and saudi arabia uh i would like
lower taxes not higher taxes less
bureaucracy now more bureaucracy now
you're a democrat tulsi do you disagree
with any of my plans what things i'd
like to do
um ish we should have a conversation
about each of those things sean we
probably agree on some disagree on
others but all right here's one should
we should we enforce the laws of the
border let's go through them one by one
of course okay so we shouldn't have open
borders we should go back to the trump
policies you'd be okay with that i've
been very vocal about that that open
borders are a threat to our own homeland
security and with open without with open
borders we don't really have a country
okay now we have a 41-year year high of
inflation and record high gas prices now
we can finish the keystone xl pipeline
very quickly and every day we'll get 900
000 barrels of canadian oil
right into the united states would you
go forward with that and would you lift
the restrictions that joe biden put on
anwar
and federal land leases for fracking and
oil would you would you join me in that
i would look forward i'd look forward to
a plan that ensures our energy security
in a way that serves the interest of the
american people and is done so
you're kind of ducking a little bit i'm
asking very specifically keystone
pipeline you're in favor of
whether it's the keystone pipeline or
other resources that we have available
here in our country you would support
security
and done so in a way that's responsible
and not contaminating water as but i'm
asking very specific questions in parts
of the country would you remove the
restrictions and regulations that joe
biden put on the energy sector and that
means
allowing more leases to be given to oil
and gas companies on federal lands that
would finish the keystone xl pipeline
reopen anwar and allow these companies
to do what they do best and that's
produced the lifeblood of the world's
economy would you support me in that
effort
i support you and agree with you in
energy security i don't know
specifically chapter and verse all the
regulations and restrictions that joe
biden has put in place but i can say
broadly he has put restrictions in place
that have inhibited our ability to be
able to provide the energy that the
american people need especially during
this critical time
all right let me let me ask you this
because joe is now apparently
negotiating a new deal with iran he sent
emissaries according to reports to
venezuela he's going to meet with the
nation he called the pariah nation and
the crown prince that he accused of
being responsible for the death of
khashoggi
wouldn't it be better for our national
security for job creation to help reduce
the price of the pump and help reduce
inflation if we again became energy
independent and instead of artificially
reducing the world's supply of oil
increasing the supply of oil wouldn't
that drive down prices and wouldn't that
also help drive down inflation
it would
so you should elect me president i
should run
so
but but your partner here's the main
question that's what i was trying to get
to but your party refuses to look at the
damage they've done and shift course why
that's a great question and it's a
question for joe biden for kamala harris
and for the leaders of the democratic
party you and i have had many
conversations about how the leadership
of this party is unfortunately taking
our country in the wrong direction and
this latest initiative of this online
policy task force is just yet another
example of their self-serving ambitions
the american people need to stand guard
because they are determined to undermine
our freedom of speech and we cannot
allow them to do that because that will
bring true darkness to our democracy you
know we're getting pretty dark right now
people poor middle class people on fixed
incomes they're dying out there hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else